Chicago you're up next November 11th and
the 12th Grand Rapids December 9th and
the 10th get your tickets to those shows
on my website at ryansickler.com
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler and all your
social media I want to thank you again
whether you're new here or whether
you've been here I appreciate the love I
appreciate the support if you are
watching on YouTube please hit the damn
Subs just hit it just you're watching it
just click it because you know you want
to watch it and it's a free way to help
the show all right it really does help
out the show and if you're one of the
fans out there it's got to have more
than you gotta check out the patreon
it's called the Honeydew with y'all and
I am highlighting the low lights with
you all and you all have the lowest low
lights I have ever heard my [ __ ] life
alright it is five dollars a month it's
you get over a month free if you sign up
for a year and you're getting the
Honeydew a day early after you at no
additional cost all right if you or
someone you know out there you're like
man you I got this story it's got to be
heard please email us at honeydewpodcast
gmail.com and hopefully we'll get to do
an episode together all right the night
pass Nation Tour continues on into the
winter I can't thank you all enough
Chicago I'll see you guys November 11th
and 12th in Grand Rapids December 9th
and 10th all right that's the biz right
there you guys know what we're doing
over here we highlight the low lights I
always say these are the stories behind
the storytellers and today I'm very
excited to have this guest first time
here on the do y'all please welcome job
fidelberg welcome to the Honeydew thank
you so much I'm so [ __ ] nervous also
that was unbelievable intro you are
you're a professional like I work with
Kevin KFC a lot and I'm used to seeing
like I'm like the third mic on a two-man
show and I'm used to seeing Kevin be
able to do that and you might be a
little better than Kevin that was really
thank you man I'll let them know I'll
let them know we'll tag them we'll tag
them uh it's really a pleasure to have
you here I'm a big fan too I love you
guys I watch you guys and when I heard
you were coming I was like I wonder if
they'd want to do it and Josh Potter we
were actually at The Comedy Store it was
the Monday night show it was Josh Adam
Meyer shimmy yasho and Potter and I were
out back and we were having a smoke and
I said you know I got KFC coming this
week and he's like oh you know
fighterberg's with him I was like nah
you think he'd want to do it he's like
I'll text him so yeah thank you for
making are you kidding me I come on any
podcast ever no one invites us ever on
podcast okay so I'm super surprised by
that I think I don't know what it is we
never get into my pockets but I would
say yes to any podcast I'm over here
like he's doing a rare appearance
no it's a it's a pleasure to be here I
am I am nervous to be here because I'm
so rare rarely against I'm nervous to be
on the show but I do have one bone to
pick please are we like a big honeydew
fan huh no okay good because honeyde's
the worst fruit that's the the whole
point and I know fans are sick of
hearing this but I'm gonna tell you
quickly the whole point of it is I'm
having dinner at a diner one night uh
they bring the fruit cup and it's got
everything in it the Honey do it all I
love it I eat the [ __ ] red grapes
that I don't even like I eat around that
honeydew and I leave the [ __ ] honey
dude just because it's I don't I don't
have a passion against it I just don't
[ __ ] with honeydew it's just a watery
nothing [ __ ] fruit okay now I feel
like a buffoon but so as I'm walking out
I see the tables littered with honeydew
and I was like huh and the thought
occurred to me like well that's a
perfectly good fruit that people just
throw away and then I was like oh my God
that's who I am in life I'm this
perfectly good person that has been
tossed aside again and again and again
and I get it so I decided that instead
of you know I was saying to uh KFC like
we all live sports center on our phones
it's it's uh highlights of everything
here's what I'm doing here's what I mean
but but that's not really what the
[ __ ] going on and I want to know how
you got there and what's the real [ __ ]
behind your life and that's what
highlighting the low lights is all about
this is the that's the best [ __ ] name
that's the best like
outlook on life I've ever heard that's
unbelievable I mean I think that's 40.
it's so awesome that's so sick
well thank you
um and I am excited to have you here but
before we talk about what we're ever
we're going to talk about today please
plug promote everything you'd like
um I don't we don't have much we don't
do a lot uh so listen to KFC radio live
shows real live shows I think uh
November 10th we're in Phoenix 11th in
Denver
13th we're at the Hollywood Cemetery
here
um you guys are doing a live uh here at
the cemetery I think it's November oh
please hit me up when you're coming back
and like I want to come to that [ __ ]
yeah all right all right yeah hell yeah
I didn't know they did that over there
neither did I I'm gonna have to [ __ ]
piggyback off your [ __ ] y'all are
gone I'm like yeah lizard here's my name
I'll wait to see if it's successful out
there yeah it will be dude they they do
um movie night out there and it's packed
yeah it's a thing it's fun that's what
I'm saying that's that's great it should
be cool I hope I hope I got it right
first of all I hope I'm not completely
misspeaking Hollywood
yeah that's just not the show where the
show is
there's there's every chance possibility
of that I want to do honeydew ghost
stories at the Hollywood Cemetery that
would be funny yeah big ghost story guy
I'll if you got one I'd like no I don't
know yeah I'll say you could tell them
anything I love them I always like to be
like that's [ __ ] but then then I'm
the first guy to go tell it oh [ __ ] it I
got one I care I forget about them
sometimes I got one so one day right
this is back in high school and uh we
had I went to school in Portsmouth Rhode
Island and uh Corey's land was a street
the the school was on and the top of the
street there's old abandoned building
like really like like just the lapidated
kind of deal and I had a buddy who broke
into it right stole uh like an Indian
chief uh basically means like kind of
like a plaster type thing stole it
brings it back to his house
is it like the one that used to be out
in front of the tobacco stores in the
mall it's much smaller but like a Kramer
style yeah yeah
and uh and so he brings it home and then
the next day he comes to school and it's
like dude I threw it back in the back I
threw it back in the basement like I I
was having bad dreams like I think that
thing's haunted
so I'm like
I'm gonna go steal that thing back and
I'm gonna put it back in his room and
he's gonna be [ __ ] terrified of it so
I go back and actually take a girl on a
first date we sneak into this abandoned
building
sneak in I find that the Indian the
Indian statue whatever put in my car I
get a call from my mom like hey you
gotta go pick your brother up in Boston
so I'm like all right [ __ ] it I don't
have time to go sneak it back into his
room go pick my brother up in Boston get
in a car accident no so we're like I'm
like [ __ ] man maybe there's something to
this thing
but I leave it in my house I leave it in
my garage like I forget about it I leave
there for years and my buddy comes over
like we're in college now at this point
we're probably Junior's in college my
buddy comes over and I'm like oh [ __ ]
you know what I have I have the Indian
thing I'm gonna surprise him with it and
scare him so we go back into the garage
and I'm like hey Apes by the way look
what I have still and I throw them the
Indian thing he like it's kind of acting
kind of like scared like whoa and he
slips fall slice his hand open on uh
like a table saw and I was like all
right we're getting rid of this [ __ ]
thing
ghost story more of Just A Series of
Unfortunate Events but
all right so tell me about yourself
because I don't know anything about you
let's talk about let's talk about life
all right where are you from originally
I'm from Fall River Massachusetts okay
um and are you an only child you have
siblings oldest of four four yeah what
do you have uh younger sister uh who I'm
33 she's 31 I got a brother who's 27 and
a sister who's 30 uh 25. okay are you
guys all close very close yeah yeah
we're not one of those fighting families
are you all do on does everyone still
live local you guys see one another yeah
more or less everyone's in the Northeast
okay uh two still in the hometown one in
Connecticut me in New York and are your
parents still together they are yeah so
you gotta you had a nice upbringing yeah
I I say that I say that I have like the
kind of depression that you can only
have if you're raising like a happy home
where you really want for anything like
my depression was a Birthright you have
to go [ __ ] through it
um so what is life like growing up for
you what were you are you
uh you're the oldest so you have to help
take care of your brothers and sisters
at all or are you just out doing your
thing what's going on no way to stay at
home mom so yeah that's what your dad do
uh he stole insurance sales Insurance
still currently oh yeah yeah yeah he's
young I got young parents I think my
parents like 58 59 something like that
also like 20 when they had yeah yeah on
purpose too oh yeah were they married
then they were yeah they were married
for two years how'd they meet uh High
School sweethearts all in the same area
too yep so you meet their friends and
stuff too like from high school if you
met people they know for sure not not a
ton but like enough you know I think
like once I I feel like once you get to
the 60s you're like or borderline 60s
you got like three friends left right
you don't have I I don't think you
friends or something you carry for that
long I have mine in like chapters where
like my elementary school friends my
high school friends my college friends
yeah work friends you got like your
three or four buddies you keep forever
but aside from that so yes I've met them
all right and what's your relationship
with your dad like good very good not
weird in this we just such a weird way
to say it like it's normal it's a normal
relationship with my dad but no we had a
kid who worked uh with us who I always
remember he uh his dad was a Redskins
fan and this kid hated his dad so much
he intentionally became a Cowboys fan
but I did actually when I was really
young I was a Rangers Fan
um we were like a hockey house and when
I was really young I was a Rangers fan
and I was born in 88 so I was about six
in 94 when the Rangers won the cop and I
celebrated that went crazy and I woke up
in the morning all my random stuff was
out of my room my dad's like it was a
Bruins house
you got you got your one cup but it's a
Bruins house back to the Bruins oh my
God I had a kid come on the patreon that
told us the story that his dad was never
around and he would get to see him maybe
like twice a year and this one time it
happened to be the Patriots Raiders tuck
roll game okay he's with his dad he's
watching it and the Raiders get [ __ ]
okay and his dad had this like Raiders
lamp
all right and he gave his son this
Raiders lamp
and his son was and then you know again
he'd leave you know I see him like every
six [ __ ] months so his son becomes
this die-hard [ __ ] Raiders fan only
because his father
gave him this lamp and they watched this
game together
that's a good memory I guess so
it's not he doing with y'all
like I don't know 10 15 years later okay
and he's like why are you a Raiders fan
he goes what are you talking about he
goes I'm a Patriots fan he goes huh
he goes you gave me a Raiders lamp he
like some guy at work gave that [ __ ]
thing to me I just thought maybe I'd
give it to you he's like you gotta be
[ __ ] he ended up rooting for the team
that beat his team he's like I'm not
root for the pages he's like and then he
goes I should have thought about it I
looked around the house there's a Tom
Brady thing in the bathroom
you didn't put that together because nah
all this time he thinks the the only
thread
that of of [ __ ] yeah that he has with
his father is the Raiders like they're
like why do you like the Raiders you
live in and he lived in Massachusetts
because my dad likes him and his dad
didn't like him at all he just gave him
just shitty lamp
dude that's that's a sad story in any
sense but particularly sad story when
the time period was 15 years he said was
like the greatest football of all for
them right like you're [ __ ] in
Massachusetts you don't get to celebrate
against them yeah because your dad is
and he's not but he's not
dude every day literally every year
school's going crazy because the Pats
are back inside oh God and you're like
oh [ __ ] it it was a fumble Charles
Woodson's right yeah
that is tough dude yeah that is tough
um what's your mom like what's what's
your relationship with your mom like
it's fantastic it's great
um but she's a bit of a a nut job like
she's she's become like a character on
the show yeah where she's like uh she
likes to describe herself like her her
mother was a depression mom
um so she's like
she's she's not it's I I can't even
really think how to describe her what do
you mean by that a depression mom her
mom had depression no if I grew up in
the depression yeah great so she was
like you guys do whatever the [ __ ] you
want I don't really care [ __ ] like see I
I guess the perfect story to describe my
mom in particular
um would be my Kevin calls this my
origin story
um I got uh I get E coli when I was in
fifth grade and for any fan of honors
who's listening to the show was like
shut the [ __ ] up John we know shut up
um but I don't know
so I get um I get E coli in fifth grade
do you know how yeah okay
[Laughter]
and uh I'm sick for a while and I was
like
she's an Irish mom so she's like here's
a glass of milk you'll feel better like
it doesn't matter what kind of sickness
you had here's a glass of milk you'll be
okay and uh I keep getting sick and you
know E coli is a messy sick and I'm sick
for a long time and finally she's like
you're like throwing up and [ __ ]
everywhere everywhere it's brutal and uh
and are you still having to go to school
during this or are you just like yeah
you're still going like because you
don't know what's going on still going
to school for now she wasn't like a
force me to school because there was a
time when I didn't go to school for 18
Mondays in a row and they had to call
the police on her we're gonna come back
for that we're gonna come back
this is after that and uh and so finally
she's like all right you know what
we're going to bring you to CVS we'll
get you some Pepto-Bismol and I'm like
so angry that I'm even like like take me
to the doctor dude take me to the
hospital and so give me a Pepto-Bismol I
just chug It And Spike it and I went now
take me to a doctor
the whole thing
like that was my little like Petty Act
of kind of like fighting back so we get
to a doctor it's a hospital and they run
their tests and they find out I have E
coli and the doctor's like now he has E
coli like has have you eaten any rotten
meat lately and in the middle of my
saying no my mom goes yeah and I was
like lady I'm in fifth grade what are
you talking about how do you know for
sure I've eaten rotten meat and she was
making me American chop suey which is
like a New England type meal and uh and
she was like I have some I had a feeling
something was funny with that meat when
I was cooking it made it anyway she now
likes to say that I was the only one who
got sick so it's more about me than the
rest of the family than everyone else
but uh this was Christmas time and I end
up in the hospital for two weeks damn
right right you spent Christmas in the
hospital Christmas in the hospital
because your mom knew she gave you bad
meat because she knew she ain't bad meat
and how about this they [ __ ] come to
the hospital on Christmas Eve my mom and
my dad and they're like you good and I
said yeah I'm good you're fifth grade
yeah and my mom got me a popsicle and
said [ __ ] see you later
they went to my aunt and uncle's holiday
party which I could see out the window
which I could see out the window
Charlton Memorial Hospital Fall River
Mass the [ __ ] the [ __ ] Christmas
party was on Highland Ave he could look
out the window I'm like there they are I
[ __ ] looked out the window and I
watched I watched Santa Claus playing a
Buick LeSabre right
they would like hire Santa so yeah
from the toilet
[Laughter]
so so that's the kind of mom she is so
she's like you'll be fine [ __ ] grow
up she's like we gotta get out of here
I told that story on the podcast I think
probably maybe no maybe the second time
I ever told it I told it we used to have
asakira uh porn star uh who was our
co-host and I told her that story and
like I I always think of all like the
sad things it's funny things like that
is that joke is what this is all about
yeah and I watched her [ __ ] week she
was crying I was like crying dude that
was the first time I ever thought I was
like oh is it sad I thought it was just
like a fun funny story and she's like
she's like that's so heartbreaking I
guess I don't know I [ __ ] told the
story every day for 10 years so it
worked out pretty well for me well go
back to the what was it 18 Mondays in a
row bro what is that all about dude I
was I think I was in second grade second
grade and uh I just [ __ ] I never
liked school I hated school I failed out
of seven colleges
[Laughter]
I did it four years man you should get a
degree for now
you should absolutely got a paperwork
for that I never thought about that I'm
[ __ ] I squeezed seven colleges into a
[ __ ] four years I don't know what
degree you should have but there should
be some kind of official signature at
the bottom of it
yeah it was like I was I was the only
one in school at the time of my siblings
all four of us were born but um I was
the only one who was currently in school
so I was in second grade and uh my mom
was always like a mental health day
Advocate which was ahead of her time
like you know this is early 90s and she
was like mental health day I'm not gonna
force my [ __ ] kids to school if you
don't wait whatever and I just I had on
Mondays my best friend uh he was
dyslexic and so he'd go to special needs
class on Mondays and I was like yo if
Brandon's not in class like I'm not
[ __ ] going I don't I go to school to
hang out with my boys I don't go to
school learn right then my boys aren't
there then what's the point of me being
there and so the first Monday I kind of
threw like a temper tantrum as like a
two as a second grader would do and my
mom was like [ __ ] it you know what fine
go back to bed I don't really care
whatever and I kind of realized that
power I had where I was like if I [ __ ]
enough I can do what I want and the
second Monday came around
did the same thing
she's like all right fine [ __ ] it
whatever I don't care go back to bed
third Monday a little less by the fourth
Monday she wasn't even waking me up
anymore she was like John just doesn't
go to school on Monday
and then it got to the point where like
probably six Mondays in teachers in
school like I I almost became like a
legend in school teachers would be like
hey it's the Monday off kid and like
teachers who didn't even know me like
fifth grade teachers like oh that's the
Monday off kid and then it got to the
point I think it was the the number is
Up For Debate we no one really remembers
the number but we do know that it was
the the police were called on Earth the
truant police
you know I was in second grade so I
don't really know if it was a regular
cop who was just kind of coming on call
with like there actually is like the
true and cop whatever it was but it was
like the police came like he has to go
to school he has to go back to class
yeah we uh my daughter's mother and I
just got a friendly call from the vice
principal at her Elementary School who
likes me because she happens to be a
die-hard Ravens fan also so she and I'll
shoot the [ __ ] whenever I drop her off
and stuff so she's like hey um just this
is a friendly call
um
because I've taken my daughter out of
school like to go visit her cousins in
October because I'm like you know what
[ __ ] it we live all the way out here
it's more important right now than first
grade to go spend a weekend with your
cousins in October I'm gonna do a show
you get to come we're gonna hang out
it's Halloween like let's [ __ ] go and
then you know a couple things here and
there and they were like listen an
approved or excuse me an excuse to
absence isn't when both parents are cool
with it
all right oh she's like so don't be so
honest when you say it's for vacation
dude I'm learning that like right now
I appreciate the call but y'all didn't
want our kids at that school for two
[ __ ] years now all of a sudden you're
gonna call us and she said don't
escalate it I'm like hey no escalate
nothing over here you didn't even want
kids in that school now you're gonna be
bitching if they're not there yeah go
Ravens
particular that age if if the parents
are like it's cool they're not coming
that should be absolutely [ __ ] cool I
feel like that's happening more often
now where like every once in a while
you'll see like a teacher that goes
viral where like they sent the parent
home of the note that's like Hey we're
the third grade class I don't assign
homework have the kid go play yeah go
have a childhood play games with your
kids 100 and like I I again it happens
viral occasionally so maybe it's more in
my mind than it actually is happening
but like that's so much more important
getting to spend your family or have a
childhood than it is to like I know you
passed some proficiency exam that the
state makes you take well I know I mean
I got the presidential uh Physical
Fitness Award I was a 3 3.0 student I
wasn't a 4.0 student but
the things I remember from my childhood
are those things yeah like moments with
my grandmother cousins family stuff with
my dad my brother's fishing crab and I
don't you know school was
[ __ ] I hated it I just it was get your
homework done as soon as you get home
and then you can go play do whatever you
want so I've always I sort of taken that
into my life too like if I have
responsibilities on the table I'm not
gonna go [ __ ] off until let me get this
[ __ ] out of the way and then I'll get
that done you know see that I wish I had
that because I don't have that I have
let's [ __ ] off let's [ __ ] off let's [ __ ]
off oh [ __ ] it's dude time to get it
done listen I'm not saying
procrastinate a lot but not all the time
you know I think you've procrastinate as
long as like until it bites you in the
ass and unfortunately I've got well I
think a lot of people would say fail
around seven colleges yeah let's get
back to that
um I just hate like the same thing like
you're saying like I hated school I did
not you said but there's a difference
between failing out and just leaving no
it was it was like you're still there
they were like you probably should like
have you like thought of like a trade
school like this isn't for you
um but yeah nothing nothing of note ever
really happened it was just who's the
seventh University looked at your record
was like we'll tell you okay
well it gets it's a bit of a cheat
because it did get it got to the point
where like I was no longer enrolled in
school they're taking classes on a on a
[ __ ] track but it was like it was I
started at St Michael's College which is
in Burlington Vermont I did a little
East Coast tour okay and then I went to
UMass in Burlington that's nice up there
yeah it's [ __ ] nice yeah that's nice
um I I actually guessed so I studied
abroad when I was in high school I went
to a boarding school and I studied
abroad then I wanna come back to that
um uh I said it abroad then and so I
guess you could count those two colleges
with like URI and University of
Salamanca I don't count them I don't
think I lose I lose track of those
almost like I lose track of the days how
many days I missed the Mondays I lose
track of the uh colleges but it was St
Michael's to UMass Dartmouth
to Florida State where that was my
longest tenure I did two years at FSU
did you yeah yeah yeah I never went to a
[ __ ] class once but that's still a
party we were talking about that with
Bert last night when Bert was like dude
I graduated yeah I didn't think you must
have like whatever however Madison you
think you are I was worse because I
didn't graduate
um but then but in your defense if you'd
have done six more years you could have
got your Bachelor stuff
I don't know man I went to like three
classes the whole time you said seven or
eight years he's there he's there
forever you should get it most people
have their doctor
um but they then I went up to uh went
back to UMass Dartmouth after that then
Providence College then NYU
writing classes like it wasn't I wasn't
enrolled in NYU but what was it about
why would you keep doing that if you
didn't have a passion for it did you
feel like you had to was there so that's
the only reason I ever went to college I
I just had a conversation with uh my
daughter's mom about it too like I don't
know that I'm gonna push I'm not gonna
push College like if she wants to be a
lawyer and or a doctor or whatever and
and you still have to go to college for
to do this then okay but if she's gonna
go creative or anything like that man
[ __ ] College [ __ ] [ __ ] College see I I'm
like my family if you have to now that's
it if it's part of the job you want to
do and you got to go to four years of
this and two years okay okay but if it's
not [ __ ] College absolutely 100 the
percent agree like I I I and like part
of it is like kind of like
like being self-centered I guess we're
like I don't need to be here [ __ ] it but
it was it was it was the worst decision
of my life but also I'm older than you
I'm I'm 49 how old are you I'm 33. okay
so
um 49 my parents come from a generation
of if you want to get better yourself
you got to go to college most of them
didn't go to college so what you're
hearing from the people who did go to
college a lot of it now is [ __ ] [ __ ]
college right right so let's listen to
the people who went there and went
through it and are saying [ __ ] College
not the people who didn't go who are
encouraging you to do this extra
education because you think that
automatically it's going to better you
in life and that's not true necessarily
for a lot of people I know it is for
some of y'all it is but for a lot of
people it's not so listen to the people
that are saying [ __ ] College because
it's a loud voice and it's it's
absolutely true yeah you're absolutely
right even like even when I was growing
up and like I it would seem that like my
parents forced me into college but they
they didn't it was just like something I
thought right like Society forced me
into college and for me at that time I
have no parental guidance at all so I'm
just going to college because that's
what I think I'm supposed to do I don't
know I'm supposed to do this next level
[ __ ] I'm supposed to get this degree and
I'm supposed to do go out in the world
and then make something of myself and
I'm like not for everybody yeah you
think it's just a step and it's a step
you can skip some of them you can jump
over
um boarding school tell me about that
why what age are you going and why are
you going to a boarding so I cheated a
little bit I I went to boarding school
it was a boarding school but I was a day
student so like it was what is a board
what exactly is the boarding school
what's different about it
um so I it was reports with Abby is
where it was
um and it's supposed to stay over though
right they they're like they're probably
60 day students in the school maybe some
maybe less than that they're about 400
kids total maybe 60 a day students
um I'm gonna I'm gonna mess up the
numbers but I remember being very proud
when I went there that like I want to
say it was 27 27 states and 19 countries
or something like that went to the
school oh wow so it's not just a local
school no no no no no they were kids
from Korea they were kids from the South
America kids from Europe like it was
people from everywhere which I I thought
was a very cool experience they
it did kind of [ __ ] me a little bit
though because I stopped uh washing my
face because a British kid told me that
if you use soap you get acne and uh I
stopped washing my face from high school
until Whitney Cummings made fun of me
like last year you know what's funny I
saw your new facial routine and I gotta
tell you are glowing you're glowing
you're glowing
but no so I kind of cheated it being
that it was it never even just put water
on it or anything I put water on it that
was it but no so that was the only thing
I never took even a rag and just wiped
the dirt off of it
over two decades
to take your hands at least with the
water yeah like splash water like that
and that would be the [ __ ] end of it
um but yeah I learned a lot more
important things at school than than
washing your face isn't it funny that
one thing this one kid tells you at this
one moment and it just it it [ __ ]
sticks with you for two decades for
nothing that's the way I am with
everything though like if you tell me if
you tell me something right now done
this [ __ ] British kid I don't even
remember he's over there lathering his
[ __ ] up he don't even remember telling
you that I believe that [ __ ] forever man
I still haven't had an almond since like
2008 because the guy in a gym told me
almonds make you hungrier it's okay if
you're trying to cut weight almonds make
you hungry and I was like I'm not
touching [ __ ] almonds anymore
well you know that eating celery is
actually you burn calories while you're
eating it I didn't know that did you eat
celery because of that yeah like it's
buffalo wings
they bring out a whole tray of buffalo
wings I send it back full I just like
one of the celery things there's nothing
quite like the smell of fresh baked
bread coming right out of the oven
especially on a chilly morning during
the holidays Wild Grain is here to give
you just that without all the hard work
Wild Grain is the first baked from
Frozen box for artisanal bread plus they
have amazing rolls pastries and even
handmade pastas Wild Grain uses only
clean ingredients and utilizes a slow
sourdough fermentation process that's
healthier for you and it tastes better
than anything you can find in a grocery
store every item bakes from Frozen in 25
minutes or less Plus for every new
member while Grayden donates six meals
to the Greater Boston Food Bank they've
donated over 120 000 meals so far this
holiday season Wild Grain is featuring
delicious new limited time sweet treats
such as pumpkin cinnamon rolls orange
cranberry biscuits and chocolate
Avalanche croissants all you have to do
is sign up at walgreens.com honeydew and
choose which type of box you want to
receive and how often it's easy to
reschedule skip or cancel I got a box
myself in the croissants are flaky the
bread is amazing but I'm telling you
they're frozen pasta took me right back
to what my grandma used to make hungry
already for a limited time you can get
thirty dollars off the first box plus
free croissants in every box when you go
to walgreens.com honeydew to start your
subscription you heard me free
croissants in every box and thirty
dollars off your first box when you go
to wildgrain.com
honeydew that's wildgrain.com honeydew
or you can use promo code honeydew at
checkout chill out all summer long with
Dad grass because it's too nice out to
be couch locked they'll mellow you out
while keeping your head clear and ease
away the stress of the day Dad grass is
legal organic hemp that relaxes your
body and Mellows your mind that grass
CBD product trucks are made with 100
organic hemp that's easy to dose and the
effects come on smooth they offer a
variety of products from their smokable
pre-rolled joints which are my favorite
as well as hemp flower and a variety of
CBD tincture drops enjoy the effects of
CBD while keeping a clear head all that
grass products are federally legal for
ages 18 and over and it ships right to
your door anywhere in the U.S go to
dadgrass.com honeydew to check out their
products so whether you're looking for a
new Buzz or a chill way to enjoy an old
favorite that grass will leave you in a
euphoric mood right now that grass is
offering my listeners 20 off your first
order when you go to daggrass.com
honeydew go to daggrass.com honeydew for
20 off your first order that's that
grass.com honeydew lately I've been out
on the night pants Nation Tour having to
watch my Ravens games from the phone and
actually it's been great and one reason
it's been great to listen to is because
I use my Raycom wireless earbuds to do
it raycon's everyday earbuds look feel
and sound better than ever and with
optimized gel tips for the perfect inner
ear fit these earbuds are so comfortable
and they will not budge trust me raycons
give you eight hours of play time and a
32 hour battery life raycons are priced
just right you get quality audio at half
the price of other premium audio Brands
it's no wonder raycon's everyday earbuds
have over 50 000 five-star reviews
raycon's three customizable sound
profiles mean no matter what I'm
listening to it sounds great and I can
easily switch to awareness mode to hear
flight announcements without pulling my
whole earbud out go to buy raycon.com
today and use code honeydew 15 to get 15
off your raycon order that's code
honeydew 15 at byraycon.com to score 15
off by raycon.com code honeydew 15. nah
that's back to the do so why boarding
school uh my dad went to one and then so
me and my dad used to go to uh because
in New England the Pats were a more
recent team right and so my grandfather
had season tickets to the Giants because
when he was becoming a fan the Giants
were New England's team I think they had
their training camp up in Vermont
actually in Burlington I think
um and uh so me and my dad he had those
season tickets like throughout my
childhood I mean my dad would go to one
game a year and we'd always take the
train down is that right so before the
New England dominance most fans up there
were root for the Giants a lot of the
older fans the older fans yeah yeah like
it's all it's all all my grandparents
yeah
um but I don't know what year the paths
were founded but it was because because
the Giants had training camp in New
England they were kind of adopted as
their team at least that's the story
I've been told
um and uh so we take the train down to
uh to the game once a year and train
goes through Connecticut my dad went to
boarding school in Connecticut and uh
one day he was just like hey you know
like you know I went to boarding school
right and I was about like seven I was
like I'm not seven I was 15. and uh I
always say like if I'm telling a story
in his childhood I always just say seven
because I never know
um
that I said you know I went to boarding
school right yeah and he said would that
be something you're interested
yeah sure whatever I'm I'm a follower
I'm pretty easily directed and uh he
went okay cool and the next morning I
woke up with like 15 pamphlets like he
definitely he had them like in his
holster right he's just ready I had like
15 pamphlets bedside me like what do you
know these boarding schools Oh I thought
we were just [ __ ] talking dude
but he it was his rule with my mom was
that it had to be
um a local boarding school that I could
be a day student at because he thought
he missed out on some of his childhood
going to one all right an actual
reporting one and how old are you when
you're about to start this uh 50 I I
went to a public school my freshman year
so I was 15 16 no 14. so you happen to
have fortunately this Kick-Ass boarding
school right where you could commute yes
yeah where obviously everyone else Korea
whatever you [ __ ] live there yeah
like one of my best friends I met down
there from New Orleans and I was like
how the [ __ ] did you find this place and
I guess that's it's a profession that
there's like people who in like the
South where there aren't boarding
schools or at least not New England
boarding schools
um they're basically like recruiters so
what is the purpose of a boarding school
I don't really what are they selling you
on what are they religion I mean like uh
it's religious mine was Catholic
maybe but Catholic all right um but yeah
we had like monks on campus and [ __ ]
like that I don't really know what the
point of it is to be honest other than
like you know they argue it's a better
education I think education you kind of
get what you put into it you can get a
good one no matter where
um but I I definitely got I learned a
lot at it like as far as routine and all
that kind of [ __ ]
um outside of facial routine they've
never talk to them either the religion
so much didn't really stick with me uh
the religion is still making me because
dude there was one day we had to go to
church every Tuesday and Sunday we went
to school six days a week Monday through
Saturday and uh there was one I'll never
forget this there was one time uh
Brother Joseph was talking on on a
Tuesday where he's talking about the
Bible and how like everything's not
meant to be taken literally and yada
yada and uh which is just moving the
goal post if you ask me but the uh the
um he said he's like he's like you know
and like every story about Jesus wasn't
put into the Bible like there's a story
where Jesus when he was a child he made
another kid disappear because he
wouldn't share his toy with him now why
would we put that in who would believe
that I was like uh [ __ ] me like if
they if you're trying to sell me on a
supernatural being the guy the one who
doesn't know his powers at that time and
makes a kid disappear she wouldn't share
his toy that sounds realistic to me
we're not realistic but like that's
believable right that sounds believable
but there's nothing about like his
childhood and [ __ ] like that
um but I was I was I was not a fan of
the religious aspect of it and so 10th
11th and 12th grade there all there yeah
and I mean some people would say that
boarding schools were Sports
um I our school was not particularly
like colleges for sports I did 70s seven
um but yeah it was it was I loved it
that that was if I had to say like what
the best part of my life was I would say
then those those are my Glory Days which
is a boarding school which is a real sad
thing to say but it is it's also the
truth like that was that was when I was
the most me ever I think now do you have
uh are your grandparents alive do you
have a close relationship with them um I
had I had a close relationship with one
grandfather uh he is he's he passed away
uh but I have one grandfather still
alive who not a bad relationship but
it's not you know we talk a few times a
year is he local he's local yeah he's in
Boston yeah and what about grandmoms
table fast yeah yeah dude there was when
my when my one grandmother passed I was
living in Boston and she was living in
Boston as well the grandfather who's
living it's his
life
um and I was living in Boston there's
probably 24 and I get a call like nine
o'clock Saturday morning
John your grandmother passed away you're
gonna have to go go over to the
apartment and see what's going on and I
was like all right hungover [ __ ] the
only 24 year old in Boston oh they're
going with Sox game the night before
whatever hung over [ __ ] and uh I go over
to the apartment and my grandfather
opens the door and gives me a hug you
know your grandmother's in the other
room
that's what you talking about my dad
said she died he's like she's dead
were you mean she's in the other room
he's like if you want to just go say
goodbye like dude I am too hung over
here
is she peacefully in the bed
behind her back yeah
[Music]
she's got blood poisonous
could you just throw out some adjectives
before I go in there I didn't go I was
like I'm gonna go in the living room
I was like dude I'm hungover I'm going
to living room to put TV on put on
Sports Center could you grab me a beer
and you just sat there and waited with
him while they came and got the body
yeah oh my God not a fun experience
[Laughter]
and what about that's your whose dad was
our Uh uh Mom was that that was my dad's
mom your dad's mom yeah and that was
later in life that was you know I I
didn't really have much law my mother's
mom passed away when I was really young
but like almost in in those formative
years I didn't really have a lot of loss
I had one before I have memories and
then the rest of them went like my 20s
30. her dad you were closer with yeah
yeah yeah what was he like he's a judge
he was a man yeah really yeah he was a
[ __ ] man was he tell me about him he
he's just an old Irish guy who uh a
lawyer first lawyer first yeah he uh
kind of one of those like like grew up
poor he he was like kind of the I guess
he would be like one of the success
stories of our family I want to ask you
this because this is my own ignorance
can you get to be a judge without ever
being a lawyer first like you can be a
head coach in the NFL without ever
having a [ __ ] play and you be a judge
without having to uh study law from
another angle I can't give you a
definitive answer I'm gonna guess 100
yes you have to be a lawyer but I I
don't know for sure
um but yeah I went to like uh Suffolk
College up in Massachusetts University
of Massachusetts put himself through uh
George Washington or Georgetown law and
then um yeah and then so he he's like
kind of like the grew up poor kind of
made something of himself kind of deal
but he's just just [ __ ] he's actually
one of the people I miss the most in the
sense that like he was so he was wise
right like I don't know any wise people
anymore tell me some give us some wisdom
I don't know if all of us could use it I
don't have anything really specific like
nothing stands out that he ever said
anything to you or like man so wait
you're telling me
the UF a judge for a grandfather had
excuse me who's one of the wisest men
you ever met you can't tell me what
thing he said but you can remember this
10 year old [ __ ] British kid telling
you not to wash your [ __ ] face
[Laughter]
I
can give you the the the best advice he
ever gave me is don't die yeah yeah I've
seen that literally in the sense that
like so he because you know he's a judge
he's obviously a real sharp mind he's
sharp as attack uh up until the day he
died but he [ __ ] went through hell
man like his last 15 years of life were
just a battle like always in and out of
the hospital always different kind of
surgeries he ended up like uh
epinephrine I think was a painkiller
used to find him during a surgery and
then he was allergic to that so they had
to cut off his arm no foot cut off some
toes on the other foot and he was like
he always told my mom he's like until my
mind goes do not like don't let me die
he's like it wasn't one of the character
basically hacking a heart on his way out
as long as I'm still here and that's
[ __ ] I'm gonna be here and that's a
medical mistake I mean you don't just
your arm just doesn't [ __ ] fall off
in your 70s
holy [ __ ] and he was like I don't give a
[ __ ] as long as I know who everybody is
and I can still know what's going on
exactly if I can have a conversation
if I'm a bust on the [ __ ] fireplace
keep me alive
which is uh I kind of like that it's not
like as long as I'm still here he's also
from a a man from a different generation
too you know what I mean like those guys
are like what are you being such a [ __ ]
exactly yeah dude I was saying that with
Bert last night where Bert was talking
about one of his dogs I forget if it was
Mac or Izzy but uh has anxiety I was
like can you imagine telling your
[ __ ] grandparents that my dog has
anxiety it would take that dog out back
and they'd kill him
anymore [ __ ] up Grandpa don't worry
about it ran away I gotta leave dinner
early and get home and give the dog its
pills in case there's a thunderstorm
tonight
[Laughter]
definitely what's going on
the dog needs its mess you know why
storm Normandy right oh yeah
bro I [ __ ] fought fascism man
just throw it up on my back while we're
getting ready to be shot
you can't eat peanuts get the [ __ ] out
of here
but
I tell that I tell that story because I
had a uh
I had a situation with the next
girlfriend where it was like uh
things went bad things were bad it was
like
suicidal threats and all that kind of
stuff like pregnancy if hate pregnancies
and kind of [ __ ] like that and uh I one
morning I woke up and I had [ __ ] I
spit blood into the sink like mouthful
is Bloods like woke up gagging ran to
say spit just [ __ ] red everywhere and
uh I [ __ ]
I pull my lip down to see what the like
because I can feel like it hurt all down
here
I'm gonna pull my lip down and it looks
rotten like all my gums look [ __ ]
rotten I call my dentist I was like I
gotta come in like I got an emergency
and I used to treat tobacco a lot so uh
I was thinking like it's something like
cancer finally got me or some [ __ ] like
that and uh I get to the dentist and uh
he's like all right sit down look at my
mouth he goes well first things first
it's not cancer I know you're scared of
that I was like all right did you have
your mom's meat again
let's go deeper here he goes uh he goes
uh
um because well like can I ask you do
you have any stress in your life right
now and I was like buddy doctor came why
don't you sit down I'll tell you right
and uh and he goes because what you have
is a thing called trench mouth
and I was like I have what and he's like
it's what they got in World War One in
the trenches and it had nothing to do
with the bacteria it had to do with the
stress and anxiety of being scared of
like Agent Orange
and I was like are you [ __ ] kidding
me that men used to fear biochemical
weapons and now this chick's scaring me
like I have the same fear like my
forefathers had in the [ __ ] trenches
fighting patches
not even the sequel the original she
left me a voicemail shaking a bottle of
pills and saying she's gonna end it that
[ __ ] put me in the same state as them
this [ __ ] German tax
that's all the stress they got this is a
little bit of [ __ ] down here yeah yeah
that's all yeah they woke up spinning
blood once or twice and they went back
to war
damn so what was going on through your
in your life at that time what's what
what's some of the like
I mean with going through all these
colleges are you like just trying to
find your place and when yeah and then
when do you
um I I would argue I still haven't
really I I oh you you're on the right
path so when does that find because
College definitely wasn't it College
wasn't it but I think that was because
of me like that was my fault like I I uh
I was
popular I guess in high school like I
was a good athlete it was fun it was
cool right so like no the our school
actually never really had like because
it was so small didn't really have those
kind of clicks like everyone's friends
so it wasn't like I was part of the
popular crew but like people liked me
and like that was fine so now I would
get to college and we'd do those
orientation type things and because I
was like I was cool dude I was too cool
to do that [ __ ] and so like I wouldn't
go to play The Name Game or whatever
[ __ ] [ __ ] you do with orientation
and guess what you owe me anyone that
way so then like I wouldn't have any
friends and then I'd like well I don't
be friends why do I [ __ ] like it here
and then I think well I'll go I'll try a
new place they'll make friends there but
there I'd still be like I'm too cool for
friends and I never really never I never
found my place in college even when I
like I joined the fraternity when I went
to FSU hoping that would do it did not
fit in there at all
um what'd you have to do to get in
nothing because how about this I played
Club hockey at FSU and ice hockey yeah
oh you play hockey yeah okay Florida
state has a [ __ ] ice it's a club
hockey team that at the time wasn't
particularly good I don't know how
they're doing now
um but like I remember when I first went
to like tryouts they were like all right
who here has a hockey experience
everyone raised their hands like who has
ice hockey experience like everyone put
their hands down I was like this is the
ice hockey team guys it's like the [ __ ]
you mean you've never played ice hockey
before
um but uh maybe because in the
fraternity they thought that that was
like an actual sport like I was equal to
[ __ ] Jameis Winston they thought we
were on the same plane and uh so they
didn't make me do anything and then but
then the hockey team knew that like
fraternities Were King so like I could
call out a practice for hockey so you
had to do frat stuff I could call out a
pledge stuff at the fraternity saying to
do hockey stuff and I could sit at home
and not hang out with anybody and get
the [ __ ] yeah and not meet more friends
meet people
I think I could lie to both
organizations I joined to make friends
you found a lot of loopholes to stay
alone
I was really depressing here right here
um
but yeah I forgot what I was saying
there just when you really started to
feel like at home and like where you
started to start to think all right
maybe I got something here
um
like what do you do right out of college
you after after college is done the
reason I stopped going to NYU where I
was just taking classes was I got an
internship at Barstool okay
um so that was 12 years ago right
um again internship at bar stool and uh
I was I was Kevin's intern that's KFC's
intern and um I got I got really lucky
with that because I was one of the
finalists in The Boston intern search
and uh I didn't get that that gigs I
didn't know how to edit I didn't know
how to do anything and that's what they
were looking for
um but then I was like well I'll just
try New York
I'll just try New York and see what
happens there and Kevin gave me the gig
and I was very lucky for that because
Kevin right away like kind of gave me
some freedom and some like like let me
be myself where it was he's like yeah
write blog who cares whereas the Boston
intern had to be more of like a you know
Dave's pet kind of deal I think Dave
called him the intern slave and whereas
Kevin was like no I didn't dream like an
equal but he was like yeah if you want
to work work you're gonna try to try
your best
um and then that kind of that that
spiraled into Dave being like who is
this guy like where's he from and he
found out from Massachusetts probably
back to Massachusetts worked there until
we moved offices six years ago but like
I mean I guess yeah I mean if you asked
an outsider if you ask someone else like
have I found my place they'd probably
say yeah of course he's been at barcel
for 12 years he's one of the first
employees he's got a successful podcast
but I don't think at all that I've found
my place well I I've never been
comfortable walking into a room being
like
I have I have myself I've are you happy
with what you do do you like working for
you those are different questions I like
working for me uh I I guess yes I am
happy with what I do yes I I don't think
I'm happy with
life but what's your place then what do
you see yourself doing ultimately I
I've said that um
one day
and it probably is sooner later in your
house 30 33 three okay I I hope to just
disappear and like go up to we've
actually BB Cooper yeah
we've invented a city it's stepping
stone Vermont we're like I just go to
this little town of Vermont and I
[ __ ] write for the local paper and I
ski and I hang out and that's like I'm
not on the internet anymore I'm not
public anymore you know but that would
be
but that that's that's the seven year
plan we'll call it by 40 we're [ __ ]
out of here really out by 40. I mean I'm
joking a little bit but yeah like I
thought it could be you would if I could
be I probably would I I I don't like
I it's just like it I don't
I don't like logging onto the internet
every morning it does not make me happy
I I've I for a long time I've tried and
distanced myself more and more which is
like it's hard in our line of work right
yeah you gotta put some goddamn content
I'm trying to get away from this [ __ ]
right yeah and it is like the the
comments and stuff like that bother me I
know a lot of you like to pretend like
they're above it and like oh [ __ ] it I'm
not gonna listen that's because you were
loved right that's because you were
loved A lot of people it doesn't bother
like my mom told me she hated me bro
right right [ __ ] your comment yeah
you're a pool guy with nine followers
that [ __ ] like dude I mean I'll get 100
100 like 100 positive comments you know
I remember the one that wasn't
um and it is like I've tried to I I've
mute you know you get a bad comment I
mute that person [ __ ] it they're never
gonna hear from them again but like
every day it definitely wears on me like
I just logging in every day it's like
it's I could I could feel it chipped
away and I hope to salvage a little bit
by the end of this
so what do you do you want to be a dad
you don't you see yourself being a dad I
don't not want to be a dad if it happens
it happens
um I can't I can't see myself being the
dad I don't think I'd be a good one why
very selfish
um and uh and I think that's okay I
actually think selfish gets a bad rap
where I think like look we only got one
of these laughs if like I I'd like to do
the things I want to do I don't know
like I I really love traveling I really
love doing what I want to do when I want
to do it and I realize that if I have to
care for someone else that's not my
option yeah
um so like if it's it's not In Like A
Five-Year Plan a 10-year plan you know
maybe one day but currently right now
I'm not like I'm not having a vasectomy
tomorrow but currently right now I no I
don't I don't want kids and do you have
any your parents seem very supportive is
there any pressure from them oh [ __ ] no
no no they don't mind that's four you
have three kids uh for you therefore
totals yeah and they're not pressuring
any of you no oh but I I'm like my
sister is pregnant I guess maybe by the
time she might have had oh yeah
um is that your first gonna be an uncle
the first time first time are you
excited about that I'm very excited yeah
I think it'll be cool
um but I think you'll be a good a better
uncle than a father
I think so I don't think I'd be a bad
dad but again like I said I just want to
be you know with the uncle you have
exactly that exactly I'm out yes my
grandmother used to say all the time
when we leave she's like I love you to
come I love you to go
shut up Grandma that is [ __ ] awesome
you're not stuck here am I
um but yeah yeah no I'm very excited I'm
a Godfather which isn't the same thing
at all I think I think maybe in some
relationships it is
um but I'm a Godfather dude kid who
actually just moved out east but he used
to be out here in San Diego oh I barely
met in most of his life
um so that's not really being a
Godfather I'd send him presents on his
birthday that's basically what I did uh
but I'm excited I'm excited maybe and
maybe being an uncle will change things
but right now like when I started for me
yeah yeah
the like I got every every kid I see
like I don't have any connection to I
don't have any love for so maybe this
will be different but like every every
kid I see I'm like I look at the parents
I'm like I know you'd be happier if that
wasn't here like previously in New
Yorkers he'd be like hot dripping sweat
pushing a stroller like wouldn't it be
nice to be able to just pop into that
bar and have a cold beer and chill out
for a little bit you ain't doing that
yeah instead of going to the [ __ ]
Eminem's Eminem store I got a kid and a
puppy I'm like what the [ __ ] I got so
much to consider anytime I go out
somewhere I'm like y'all kid friendly
yeah you got crayons yeah you got
puppies yeah all right even even puppies
I I love I have my family as a dog I
love my dogs
um but personally like I I live with my
girlfriend for a while uh we sensible it
up but the she was she really wanted a
dog and I was like when I come home from
work I just want to chill like that's
probably that love is probably something
that's missing in my life and probably
would do me well
um but I'm like I don't want a
responsibility I kind of wanna just
[ __ ] hey I'm a man child I'm a I'm a
Peter Pan yeah yeah yeah you're not
interested in growing up I not right now
and it's not like
I'm sure I that's the thing I should
be interested in it
right now I'm not
what do you what do you are you scared
of something
or are you just enjoying everything so
much you just don't
want to [ __ ] change it's a good
question I don't really know I I am
enjoying what I do I I think again if
you want to talk like core happiness
probably not which probably relates to
the other stuff again
um but the like I'm enjoying stuff I
don't I don't really I'm having fun
right now I'm having fun out in La all
this stuff
um I don't I don't have an active fear
like there's nothing in my Forefront of
my mind I'm short subconsciously there's
[ __ ] but I don't have any like active
fear of of growing up or getting old or
anything like that it's just
not into at the moment it's interesting
I hear your your life and it's you know
boarding school and then the colleges
and right in the bar stool
so I'm not hearing anything in my life
like building above ground pools and
working at UPS shots UPS Baltimore
Maryland
um you know lifeguard oh I had all those
junkyards and but I mean you you go into
a pretty damn good uh
gig well I mean the time barcel was not
a good game that's that's what I'm
saying yeah it wasn't at first
um
Saturdays are for the boys
[Laughter]
is that you that that is uh me and a
stranger at a bar in Newport Rhode
Island well tell me about it that was uh
that was uh
we were we were out with friends and
some old dude at a bar just kind of like
raised the glass to nobody in particular
he was his newport's like a shipping not
a shipping down a sailing Town
um so it was kind of like a a fair a
seafared man like kind of like the
grizzly bear kind of the the leather
skin and he just went gentlemen
Fridays are for the men
Saturdays are for the boys and like I
honestly I to this day I don't know what
the [ __ ] it means uh I guess in Friday
you're at work and you know it's mendu
and Saturdays like when you're the boy
out and you kind of just rip and run
um that's how I've taken it I don't I
don't really know what it means and I
tweeted it and it kind of just went
crazy like it went which actually is
funny now looking back on it it's really
not that Viral if you go find the tweet
it really isn't isn't that fine like
compared to obviously 50 tweets today
far more viral than that was
um but people are resonated with people
they liked it and like so it became this
thing that like on Saturdays
um people would just wake up and they
tweet me gifts like of like I don't know
things like like Braveheart all the boys
running in yeah that kind of [ __ ] and uh
and then that made it happen one or two
Saturdays in a row and then me and my
buddy who I was living with the time
like this might be something here like
let's try and turn this into something
so we did we started doing four
Saturdays in a row we did like something
kind of wild something one we went like
cliff jumping and like just jumped out
to clean you did it yeah yeah okay I
started with Sky diving my name is
skydiving where I was like got the video
and just jumped out
and then cliff jumping and then we
rented a yacht
um which is which that was actually kind
of my favorite video we did was like we
had a yacht like it's like a three-story
guy I don't know how the [ __ ] we got
this like it was the kid who I live was
in blue he was like a Salesman of sorts
and uh not sorts he's a hell of a
Salesman and um he's somehow finagled
his way into getting a CIA I don't know
we did not have yacht money
so somehow we got a job for that we
might have [ __ ] stolen it for all I
know and we went up with chicks and then
we just threw them all off the third the
third level we were like sorry for the
boys get the tricks out of here and then
the last one was we did a helicopter
um that's usually like reserved for
proposals where they do like they carve
marry me into the beach for you but we
had him carb size for the boys into the
beach and then we kind of seeing the
helicopter going nuts and then that kind
of just off that kind of just became and
took all it took off like probably two
years like it was it's a really really
big deal fight for an obnoxious amount
of time
um I love that I I once um when I was I
had a producing gig for a while for a
long time I'd have different producing
gigs but I worked for uh Oprah Winfrey's
network right
and they wanted us to go downtown to La
um there was this big black dude that
made delicious [ __ ] cupcakes and it
was called Big Man Bakes okay so during
the interview you know we're talking
about I'm like now how did you get this
name for Big Man Bakes and he said same
sort of thing he said he's at a par so
he said that he really liked this one
girl one time and
um they were just classmates and she
came in crying one day he's like what's
the matter she's like today's my
birthday and my boyfriend didn't get me
a cake or anything and he liked her so
much he went home and baked her a cake
and they brought her to her and it was
so [ __ ] horrible that she didn't want
to eat it but she liked the idea and
after that he decided well [ __ ] it no
one deserves to not have a cake on their
birthday I'm gonna start making cakes
which turned into cupcakes right so he
starts making these [ __ ] ridiculous I
mean this dude's Mass makes these
Kick-Ass cupcakes Okay and he takes them
to a party one night and somebody on the
other side of the room's like man
who made these [ __ ] cupcakes and then
they all pointed at the big black dude
and he goes oh Big Man Bakes he was like
boom and now he's got like three [ __ ]
chains downtown L.A and kicking ass no
[ __ ] it's awesome that's that's [ __ ]
cool as hell
well thank you for coming on here
um I'm gonna ask you this question
though I'm not done with you yet uh
because you have an interesting life I
want to know advice you would give to
your 16 year old self dude you know what
actually is unfortunate is we kind of
touched on it where I think I'd say
don't go to college I think I think I
said that's but also here you know now
that I say that out loud it kind of not
seven of them it kind of it might be bad
advice
I think like despite you know that there
was no success I have no piece of paper
I think they were important years of my
life in finding out what works for me
what doesn't work for me so maybe
College was a good idea
um
[ __ ] man uh I honestly just these are
all on my Forefront because of what you
talked about but uh I'd say spend more
time with your grandfather I I do uh I I
very often in the news these days I wish
I'm like [ __ ] man I wish I could call
cramps like he'd have some interest
interesting say interesting [ __ ] to say
about this
um not getting to spend more time with
him yeah and I I very much regret
um like just doing like that like kind
of 14 year old [ __ ] where it's like go
see your grandfather it's like no [ __ ] I
want to hang out with my friends
um which is I mean I know that's the
lamest advice I know it's not I mean I
say it all the time man my dad died when
I was 16 these days he'd been like hey
do you want to take that right up to
Kmart real quick get some I'm like now
I'm gonna play my video games yeah nah
now now I'd be like [ __ ] yeah but you're
14 you're not supposed to want to do
that I know and it's like it's the
advice that's been handed down for
centuries and it just right it doesn't
matter so it's bad advice to give to a
16 year old because it's not gonna
[ __ ] affect them one bit
um but yeah I miss I miss family I wish
I spent more time with family yeah
that's great
um would you like to plug and promote
everything again please
um if we're right who knows uh but
Denver November
10th Phoenix November 11th
Hollywood Cemetery maybe like I'm gonna
google it again uh November 12th
um but yeah looking forward to being out
here and then chaos radio YouTube and
all that nonsense dude thank you so much
for coming on dude thank you so much
yeah this is great laugh a lot it was a
good time thank you very much um as
always Ryan sickler on all social media
Ryan sickler.com we'll talk to you all
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]